and Chris there's one angle that we
didn't fully explore as it relates to
the New York Jets in their search for a
new general manager basically who will
be the next GM of the Jets Joe Douglas
the name that has come up Daniel
Jeremiah's name has been thrown out
there Louis Riddick purportedly will
interview I look they want a strategic
thinker they want a leader they you the
kind of guy they want just may not be
available right now somebody who would
perfectly fit exactly what Christopher
Johnson wants and I think it makes it
even more likely that they're going to
get a guy that Adam GaSe wants to
essentially be the glorified table
setter for gays almost like what Jon
Gruden has in Oakland with mike Mayock I
think that's what GaSe is gonna end up
with in New York yeah well III agree
with you there I don't know if gays will
get all you know overall arching power
over every move that's made the way like
Jon Gruden has and as far as that
situation I would actually hope that
Adam GaSe does not I hope that they hire
a GM that Adam GaSe will trust to make
those decisions and he doesn't have to
worry about that aspect of the business
right now and just coaches the football
team and make the team as good on the
field as possible but Joe Douglas is you
know where it started and ended from me
when we first heard these rumors you
know prior to the draft Joe Douglas was
the name I heard from a number of people
and to me I would think he is a leader
in the clubhouse you know to me and my
understanding too and I don't know all
this and I haven't made all the
connections and calls yet - I don't
think Adam GaSe enjoy Douglas have
worked together maybe I'm wrong I just
think there must be a professional you
know relationship and they've met each
other many times you know I get guessing
in the NFL circles and they they
apparently like what each other says
about football and evaluating players
and whatever it may be but Joe Douglas I
mean come on he was working with the
Baltimore Ravens for a long long time he
certainly knows what it takes to build a
successful team the years he was there
gosh they were relevant Super Bowl
playoff conversation almost every single
year got to work under guys like Ozzie
nose Newsome and erekt Acosta a lot of
great minds there and now the last few
years been with the Philadelphia Eagles
- we're just a very base an impressive
two teams Chicago Bears sandwiched in
between that's a
a good resume and some pretty good spots
that he's been at there was an overlap
between Douglas and gates in Chicago
that's where with Jay Cutler as the
quarterback thank you but here's the
thing yeah and and this is where this
whole dance of final say becomes very
intriguing because if case is gonna hold
final say you can't hire away a Joe
Douglas if he's still under contract
with the Eagles unless the Eagles are
fun and letting him go the only way you
can pluck a guy from another team who is
under contract without that team saying
yeah sure go ahead and leave and rarely
does a team do that is if you're giving
him final say traditional GM powers and
what we could have here Altima ly
because I still think Chris that gase is
gonna be the king of the Jets football
organization when this is all said and
done what we could have here is another
Eric Mangini George cockiness situation
when mangini was the coach of the Browns
and they hired George cockiness away
from the Ravens to be the GM kookiness
had final say in writing but he was
foolish enough to think he actually had
final say
mangini ran the show they put what they
had to put in the contract to get
kookiness
and it wouldn't surprise me if at the
end of the day that same kind of thing
plays out with the Jets with the new GM
ostensibly having final say but gase
running the program and I think that
gase dynamic is going to hover over this
you and if you're Christopher Johnson at
this point if you're making this move
you you want a GM that's gonna work with
your coach you want a GM that the coach
wants you don't want to bring in a GM
from scratch who's gonna say okay
everything looks fine here first thing I
got to do is get rid of the coach yeah
no I mean agreed I mean you want
somebody that yeah the coach believes in
that the coach can trust when the coach
goes to coach the football team he
doesn't have to worry about gosh I hope
this guy is doing you know his job up to
my expectation levels here why I can't
keep my eye on the personnel department
and all those things so that's why I
think it makes a lot of sense from that
standpoint I hope they don't give that
uncased full power over the roster I'm
hoping that's is why they're having this
conversation because this is a guy that
Adam GaSe trusts with the vision of the
roster and the team in general and he
knows that he can add his two cents into
the conversation and as far as
evaluating players and everything like
that anyways
but just that would be my advice that'd
be his coach the football team I know
he's capable of making roster moves I
also know in Miami it didn't go great
and I know it wasn't all his fault
because as you know as I know there's a
lot more issues going on behind the
scenes in Miami than I think people
realize so I would just like to see him
coach the team and let other people
handle the roster stuff biggest problem
in Miami there isn't an owner who lives
in town and is in the building every day
Christopher Johnson spending more time
at the jets facility it's important to
have the person who signs the checks and
can tell people to come and go
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports